joining me now to react Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire Ben it
seems like every day like there's a
there's just a panoply of fun issues
that shows the leftist totally out of
ideas and all they are is about stunts
what about this did he actually violate
us and Mexican law I mean apparently he
did apparently he walked over the border
with a bunch of his aides and then he
was asked by the Border Patrol where'd
you come from because you're not in a
port of entry and he just pointed over
toward Mexico and then he immediately
proceeded with his friends to kind of
walk back across the border in New
Mexico again I mean to be fair to Bill
DeBlasio the guy probably doesn't know
where he is half the time I mean last
week he spent in the socialist bill de
blasio spent time with the socialist
Bernie Sanders at Bernie Sanders
socialist lake house so I think that it
wouldn't even make sense to probably you
know convict him and imprison him for
illegal immigration considering he'd
probably think he was in a playpen of
Chucky Cheese or something I just know
where he is had an excuse okay we got to
listen carefully to what the mayor said
why suddenly weeks later is this letter
showing up from the federal government
well it is another attempt to distract
from an inhumane policy threats by the
Trump administration will not stop me
from speaking out and they won't stop my
fellow mayor's from speaking out been a
Profile in Courage indeed I hope he
continues to speak out at least it stops
him from throwing groundhogs you know I
would say then I will I will think we
can trade ten illegal immigrants who are
good people want to work here or do you
have family here in deport bill de
blasio so do bill de blasio goes to
Mexico well take that's a good deal
don't you think okay when we got that
settled okay I got to talk to you about
this auntie and antifa bill that
Republicans in New York have have
offered daily beast has a piece on this
and this is from Mark Berets a Dartmouth
College lecturer
whenever I see politicians talking about
nt4 the level of information they have
is minimal bark mark Bray told The Daily
Beast in a certain sense they're talking
about what they perceive as leftist
because Republicans believe you
shouldn't be
that threatened people with a mask and
call yourself a legitimate protester
what's going on there
you've been the target of radical groups
you know III think that one of the
problems here is that the bill itself is
probably too broadly drawn for First
Amendment concerns it talks about
intimidation or obstruction and these
these terms are probably a problem in
terms of just First Amendment
jurisprudence but the attempt to
distinguish an Tifa from other violent
groups that have worn masks before is
really stupid we have laws on the books
all over the United States for example
Protel you're not allowed to go around
freaking people out if you're wearing a
KKK hood for example and so this is very
similar to that in that if you're going
around attempting to do violence to
people with your face covered this is an
attempt to obstruct who you are so the
police can't catch you obviously and it
seems more like that than like anything
you know resembling a crackdown on
law-abiding citizens to me speaking of
the law and constitutional matters Ben
here's esteemed would-be jurist Katie
tore at MSNBC today let's watch based on
where Americans stand on the issues and
Americans have really moved in a much
more progressive direction over the
years do you think it's appropriate to
continue to take such a strict
originalist view of the Constitution
given it's it's 2018 and not 1776 this
is where I say kids don't try this legal
analysis at home you react oh oh the
levels of stupid 1776 the Constitution
was not yet written number one number
two if you believe that America has
evolved beyond the Constitution it has
an amendment process also we have
legislators that you can elect and
finally the idea that any of this
justifies the Supreme Court moving away
from the text of a law simply so they
can interpret the Constitution as poetry
is more evidence that the left wants the
Supreme Court December Talebi a super
legislature as opposed to you know an
actual judiciary that is using judgment
instead of will as per Alexander
Hamilton in Federalist 78 of event isn't
that scary though when you watch the
analysis of the Supreme Court pick Brett
Kavanaugh you see you see people now
criticizing his name I mean the
comedian's are going after his name okay
Brett is is is apparently a frat boy
name I've never heard that let more that
was never taking it yep my favorite
thing about the name thing is
the same people who think that Brett is
an inappropriate name for Supreme Court
justice are celebrating the cardi B just
had a kid she named culture with the K I
think I think it shows just how
desperate the left is and I'm thoroughly
enjoying the meltdowns about NATO the
meltdowns about Kavanagh the meltdowns
about you know the ante for look I love
all of it okay just all the balls have
to be juggled all at one time because
this provides unending humor for you and
me Ben Shapiro it's great to have you on
as always